la protesta comenzó pacíficamente con
manifestantes levantando seis dedos en
referencia a cada una de sus demandas
clave la más importante la retirada de
una ley de seguridad nacional que otorga
a las autoridades chinas amplios poderes
para perseguir a sus críticos pero esta
marcha estuvo motivada por una decisión
específica el aplazamiento de las
elecciones al consejo legislativo
originalmente programadas para este
domingo último ámbito del mundo
en julio la líder del ejecutivo de hong
kong kerry lama pospuso a las elecciones
por un año alegando un aumento en los
casos de kobe 19 la medida supuso un
golpe para la oposición a favor de la
democracia que esperaba obtener una
mayoría histórica en el consejo este año
mi sensación es que la verdadera razón
de la cancelación de las elecciones
legislativas no tiene nada que ver con
la pandemia creo que el gobierno de hong
kong está aquí para suprimir nuestro
derecho a expresar nuestras demandas
y las soluciones que deseamos ver y como
el futuro debería haberse
nuestros derechos están siendo abusados
a medida que la protesta se hacía masiva
la policía avanzó para disolver la
disparando gases lacrimógenos a
quemarropa alegando que las reuniones
masivos estaban prohibidas debido a la
pandemia
los oficiales arrestaron a casi 300
personas acusándolas de propiciar
reuniones ilegales e incluso tiraron al
suelo a esta niña de 12 años cuando
trató de escapar más tarde le metieron
una multa por violar las reglas de
distanciamiento social entre los
detenidos figuraban varios activistas
pero democracia incluido tan taxi una
figura destacada del grupo político
people power los funcionarios lo han
acusado de pronunciar palabras
deliciosas